بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده
ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين اما
بعد يقول
تعالى والذين ينقضون عهد الله من بعد
ميثاقه ويقطعون ما امر الله به ان يوصل
ويفسدون في الارض اولئك لهم اللعنه ولهم
سوء
الدار قوله تعالى والذين ينقضون عهد الله
جاء هذا في مقابل الذين يوفون بعهد
الله قد سبق
ابرز ما جاء من اوصاف في اهل الجنه اولي
الالباب
الذين تبشرهم الملائكه في الدنيا
والاخره وجاء ذكر
ادام من اهل
النار في المقابل يقول تعالى والذين
ينقضون عهد الله النقض هو
الحل تتصور
ان عهد الله كالحبل المشدود
المعقود بين الله سبحانه وتعالى
وعباده فاذا
عصى العبد
ربه فان هذا
العقد لا يزال ينفك
وينحل حتى
ينقض يكون
منقوض يقول تعالى من بعد
ميثاقه من بعد ميثاقه يعني من بعد ما
شد هذا
الميثاق وسمي ميثاقا لانه
موثق يعني مشدود
ومحكم فهذا يدل على
علم وقد ذكرنا سابقا ان من شروط العذاب
التعذيب
العلم يعني مثلا
انسان لا
يعلم شيئا عن دين
الله فيفعل
شيئا من السنه من سنه النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم يطلق لحيته
مثلا وهو لا يقصد
التدين ولا يقصد الاقتداء بالنبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم هل هذا يكتب له اجر الجواب لا
لا يكتب له اجر
لماذا لان
العلم
والنيه يكون الانسان قصده
الاتباع هذه شروط في قبول
العمل كذلك في العصيان الانسان الذي يحاسب
عند الله بانه عصى الله
تعالى فلا بد ان يكون ناويا ذلك العصيان
هو يعلم ان هذا
محرم ويفعل ذلك رغم تحريمه تنعقد
نيته على
العصيان
فمثلا
شخص يظن
يظن جهلا
منه
ان الشيء الفلاني
محرم مثلا يظن ولا يعلم ولكن
يظن
ان اطلاق
اللحيه من
المعاصي لاحظوا
الكلام اطلاق اللحيه سنه سنه النبي صلى
الله عليه
وسلم ومن سنن الفطره من سنن الانبياء ومن
سنن الرجال
لكن اخذنا
مثالا عن الذي يطلق
لحيته لا قصدا للسنه ولا قصدا للطاعه
وانما يطلق لحياته هل يؤجر نقول لا يؤجر
الا بنيه
الاتباع طيب جاء اخر برضه
جاهل يظن ان اطلاق اللحيه
معصيه يظن ان الله نهى عن اطلاق اللحيه
مثلا واطلق لحيته
وظن ان اطلاق اللحيه معصيه لكن في الحقيقه
اطلاق
اللحيه من
طاعه فهل يؤجر هل
يؤثم ماذا
نقول نقول
حكمه انه عصى
الله عصى الله
نعم عصى الله بالنيه المنعقده على مبارزه
الله سبحانه بالعصيان وفي
الحقيقه هذا الامر غير محرم بل هو من
الامور المرضيه عند الله لكن
نيته مبارزه الله سبحانه وتعالى
بالمعصيه
فعليه من الاثم ما
عليه وهلم جره
فالانسان
النيه والنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول
انما الاعمال
بالنيات
الانسان من اجل ان
يكون قد عصى
الله ويعاقب على عصيان الله في
الاخره فلا بد ان تكون له نيه يكون له علم
بالمعصيه ويعلم ان هذه معصيه وتنعقد نيته
وعزمه ينعقد على
فعله ولذلك قوله تعالى وما كنا معذبين حتى
نبعث
رسولا يقول تعالى كلما القي فيها فوج
سالهم خزنتها الم ياتكم نذير قالوا
بلى فقوله والذين ينقضون عهد الله من بعد
ميثاقه استحكم هذا الميثاق وهم نقضوه
قاموا
بنقضه يقول ويقطعون ما امر الله به ان
يوصل ما امر الله به ان يوصل من
الامانات
من
الرحم من القرابه من الصداقه كل شيء امر
الله به ان
يوصل ويفسدون في
الارض والافساد في الارض هنا بالمعاصي
والتعويض عن عباده الله هذه هذا افساد في
الارض ظهر الفساد في البر والبحر بما كسبت
ايدي الناس يعني من
المعصيه يقول
تعالى اولئك لهم
اللعنه فرق بين اولئك لهم لعنه واولئك لهم
اللعنه اللعنه هنا للعهد
الذهني يعني اللعنه
الكبرى اللعنه ال ال الكبرى التي تدخل
اصحابها النار مخلدين فيها والعياذ بالله
لهم
اللعنه ولهم سوء
الدار يعني سيء
الدار يقول تعالى الله يبسط الرزق لمن
يشاء
ويقدر
يبسط يعني
يوسع والشيء
البسيط في لغه العرب الشيء الواسع قال هذا
بسيط يعني هذا
واسع طبعا احنا عننا في لغتنا العاميه شيء
بسيط يعني شيء سهل ميسور خفيف لكن هذا ضد
معناها معنى هذه الكلمه في
لغه وهذا كثير ومن الغلط من الخطا ان
الانسان
يظن انه
اذا تكلم
العربيه العاميه وما درس عربيه
القران انه يفهم ولا يستطيع ان
يفهم قد مرت قرون
كثيره وط را على لسان الناس
العجمه فاصبح الناس لا يميزون ولا يفهمون
كثيرا من
كتابهم وقوله تعالى الله يبسط يبسط يعني
يوسع الرزق لمن يشاء
ويقدر
ويقدر يعني
يضيق
ف
يقول
تعالى الله يبسط الرزق يعني يوسع الرزق
لمن يشاء ويقدر يعني يضيقه
والقدر القاف والدال والراء هذه الماده في
لغه العرب تدل على تضييق
الشيء الشيء
الضيق يقول تعالى وفرحوا بالحياه الدنيا
فهذه الاشياء من الله سبحانه
تعالى الله سبحانه
وتعالى الله سبحانه
وتعالى هو الذي يبسط الرزق ويضيق الرزق
ويعطي فلانا ويمسك عن فلانا وطبعا في
اسباب صحيح في
اسباب لكن هذا
السبب لا
ينجع ولا يفلح ولا يفلج
ابدا الا باذن المسبب
سبحانه فالذي
يتباهى بالرزق على الذي يعني الذي هو
مبسوط الرزق يتباهى ويتكبر ويتفاخر
على ضيق الرزق فهذا بمنزله الذي يتباهى
طوله
على على صاحب القصر على من هو اقصر
منه او
يتباهى من له نعمه معينه والله سبحانه
وتعالى لم يعطي فلانا مثل ما
اتاه وهذا هو معيار الفخر
والبطر يقول تعالى انما
اوتيته على علم
عندي عندي
ف هؤلاء
الكفار يظنون ان صاحب
الرزق
هذا مختار عند الله او صاحب الرزق هو الذي
يسعى سعيا حثيثا فيزداد
رزقه
وهذا ليس بصحيح ليس صحيحا ان يعتقد ان ان
الانبساط في الرزق يدل على رضا الرب
سبحانه الله سبحانه وتعالى
يعطي المال من يحب ومن لا يحب ولا يعطي
الايمان الا من يحب كما قال النبي صلى
الله عليه
وسلم فهذا اول شيء والشيء الثاني ان يظن
الانسان انه اذا
اجتهد فانه يصيب من الدنيا بقدر اجتهاده
وهذا ايضا
خطا صحيح ثم
اسباب جعلها الله وهذه سنن الله سبحانه
وتعالى
في رزق عباده
لكن ليس السعي هو الشرط الوحيد في الكسب
يقول تعالى وفرحوا بالحياه الدنيا الفرح
هنا بمعنى البطر تكبروا
وبطر وتمتعوا بالدنيا ونسوا
الاخره هذا البطر وفرح بالحياه
الدنيا وما الحياه
الدنيا في الاخره الا
متاع متاع يعني
شيء
عابر
وشيء منقطع لان المتاع في لغه العرب يدل
على انقطاع ويدل
على الشيء السريع ويقول الذين
كفروا لولا انزل عليه ايه من
ربه النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم قد اتاه
الله من كل ايه زوجين في
الحقيقه حتى قال العلماء ما من نبي من
الانبياء بعثه الله
سبحانه الا واوتي نبينا محمد صلى الله
عليه
وسلم مثل ما اوتي من الايات او
افضل يعني ما من كتاب ما من وحي ينفع
الناس من وحي الله السابق الا وله ذكر في
القران وكذلك ما من ايه من ايه
الانبياء الا وله شيء اوتيه النبي صلى
الله عليه
وسلم وقد عد بعض العلماء او حاول ان
يعد ايات النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم في
القران في صحيح السنه في كتب التاريخ
كالبيهارين
فزادت على
الالف وهذا فقط ما نقل
الينا
ف ما قولهم ما معنى قولهم ويقول الذين
كفروا لولا انزل عليه ايه من
ربه
الجواب قصدهم الايه
التي هم يختارونها
ياتون اليه يقولون ان كنت
نبيا فعرج في السماء الان امامنا ولن نؤمن
لرقيك حتى تنزل علينا كتابا
نقراه والا لا لا نصدقك والذي ياتي ويتحسر
في
الايات ويطلب ايه خاصه انا لا اؤمن الا
بايه هيك توافق
هواي هذا لا يؤمن وقد انعقدت نيته على عدم
الايمان قبل السؤال
اصلا يقول تعالى ان الذين حقت
عليهم كلمه ربك لا يؤمنون ولو جاءتهم كل
ايه حتى يروا العذاب الاليم
لا انعقدت
نياتهم على الكفر هم كفروا قبل
الدليل وقالوا مهما تاتنا به من ايه
لتسحرنا بها فما نحن لك
بمؤمنين فارسلنا عليهم الطوفان والجراد
والقمل والضفادع والدم ايات مفصلات
فاستكبروا وكانوا فالله سبحانه وتعالى
يذكر ان الذي
ياتي
ويطلب
الايه توافق
هواه وقد جاءت الايات فهذا لا
يؤمن هذا لا لا يؤمن
لماذا لان المساله
بالتشهي الله سبحانه
وتعالى يعني البرهان يثبت بماذا
بايه اي ايه شيء نعلم
يقينا ان هذا لا يمكن لبشر ان يعمل
مثله وهذا شيء من الله يقينا خلاص ثبتت
الحجه جاء في الصحيحين من حديث ابي
هريره ان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم قال ما
من
الانبياء الا واوتي من الايات ما مثله امن
عليه
البشر
فكل نبي له ايه وهذه الايه الله سبحانه
وتعالى ذكر كثيرا من الانبياء ذكر 25 نبيا
في كتابه
لكن
الايات المذكوره
لنا قليله لم يذكر لكل نبي
ايه ذكر بعض الاشياء التي قد تكون ايه لكن
ابراهيم عليه السلام لما جاء قومه لما جاء
اباه وقال
لابيه اتبعني اهدك صراط سويا قبل ان القي
في
النار هل جاء بايه يقينا جاء بايه جاء
بايات لما قال لقومه جاء بايات لوط عليه
السلام جاء بايات
هود
شعيب
ا نوح عليه
السلام كل هذه هؤلاء جاؤوا بايات الله
سبحانه وتعالى ذكر بشكل عام انه ولقد
بعثنا لقد ارسلنا رسلنا بالبينات وانزلنا
معهم الكتاب
بالبينات فمعهم البينات معهم
الايات اي ايه لا يهمنا هذا غير مهم المهم
انه ابتعث الله الرسل بالايات فثبتت الحجه
لكن الذي ياتي متشه لا جيب لي ايه هيك انا
اقول لك اذا بدك اياني
اامن
اي اعرج في السماء اقول لك بدك نؤمن نؤمن
لك اذا زحت
عنا جبال مكه وخليت ه الصحرا خضراء وغاب
خلص نؤمن بك ما
هذا الهذا ارسل
الرسل وقد قوا ذلك وقوا اكثر من
ذك وانشقاق القمر منه
يعني هم طلب ذلك في بعض الروايات ف كل حال
هذه اشياء
ياتون وهم الحقيقه يتعنت الانبياء
انعقدت نياتهم على عدم الايمان مهما تاتنا
به من
ايه مش ممكن
يؤمنوا فقوله تعالى ويقول الذين كفروا فهو
سماهم
كفارا ونسبهم الى الكفر الذي هو فعل ما
قال وقال الكافرون قال الذين كفروا هذا
يدل على ماذا على انهم ما زالوا يختارون
الكفر والكفر واقع في المستقبل كما هو
واقع في الماضي ما في فرق يقول تعالى
ويقول الذين كفروا لولا انزل عليه ايه من
ربه قل ان الله يضل من يشاء ويهدي اليه من
اناب عدل عن الرد على مساله
الايه في بعض الايات قل انما الايات عند
الله
بعض الايات قل لهم انت نبي انت رسول ماالك
دخل في الايات الايات من الله لكن في هذه
الايه عدل عن المساله تماما وقال ان الله
يهدي من يشاء يقول ان الله قل ان الله يضل
من يشاء ويهدي اليه من
اناب
فعلق سبحانه وتعالى في هذه الايه
الاضلال بمشيئته
وعلق
الهدايه بفعل
العبد يعني علق ضلال
العبد بفعل الله بمشيئه الله
وعلق هدايه العبد بفعل العبد ماذا نفهم من
هذا وطبعا كل شيء من الخير والشر والهدايه
والغوا كلها بمشيئه الله انه لن يكون شيء
الا ان يشاء الله سبحانه
وتعالى وما كانوا ليؤمنوا الا ان يشاء
الله فالايمان بمشيئه الله والكفر بمشيئه
الله والعصيان بمشيئه الله والطاعه بشيئ
بمشيئه
الله
لكن في هذه الايه لفته جميله
وذلك ان
الانسان كان كان قائل قائل يقول لا
تسال عن الهالك كيف هلك اسباب الهلاك
كثيره جدا كلها تعود الى مشي مشيئه
الله منهم من في قلبه امراض منهم من فضل
غير الله على الله منهم من تعنت منهم
اسباب كثيره
تعود كلها الى ماذا مشيئه
الله وقد قال بعض التابعين هذا وهي كلمه
لعل من كلام ابن المبارك او الفضيل بن
عياض
يقول لا
تسال عن الهالك كيف
هلك ولكن سل عن الناجي كيف
نجى لان سبيل النج جاه سبيل واحد ما في
غيره واما سبيل الهلاك سب سبل
كثيره فقوله
تعالى قل ان الله يضل من
يشاء اسباب الضلال
كثيره
تلاشيه
اي يخطئها
العد تعود كلها في نهايه
المطاف الى مشيئه
الله
يقول ويهدي اليه من اناب لكن سل عن الناجي
كيف نجى كيف نجى اولئك اناب الى الله
والانابه الرجوع والتوجه الى الله سبحانه
وتعالى
بالصدق فانسان مثلا ياتي يقول ف فجعل
الهدايه ب سببه الاعظم فعل العبد صح ولا
لا وجعل الضلال وهذا في هذا
الاسلوب هذا الاسلوب الذي
ينهد الذي هداه الله هداه بمشيئه الله صح
ولا لا والذي اضله الله اضله الله بفعله
اليس كذلك فلما زاغوا ازاغ الله قلوبه
ماشي لكن في هذه الايه في هذا
الجو الله يلفت الانتباه الى هذه
المساله ليس لنا ان نحتج وهذا ما جاء في
بدايه السوره وهي طريقه الكافرين ما هي
طريقه الذين كفروا طريقتهم يحتجون بفعل
الله على امر الله يعني مثلا انطعم من لو
يشاء الله
اطعمه الله لم يطعم هؤلاء
الفقراء فهو لم
يطعمهم هذا فعل الله وامر الله على لسان
الرسول اطعم
الفقراء فهم يحتجون
يحتجون بفعل الله على امر الله على كلام
الله هذا هذا هو سبيل الهلاك تماما
تماما تاتي فلانا تقول يا فلان
صلي الله يقول واقيموا الصلاه ويل
للمصلين فويل للمصلين فيقول لو شاء الله
ان اصلي كان هداني ادعو الله لي انه
يهديني هذا سبيل اهل النار اجمعين كلهم
قالوا بهذا الكلام
كلهم
كلهم هذا هو
اعتقاد
الكافرين اعتقاد
الضالين
المتكئين الذين قد انعقدت نياتهم على
المعصيه اصلا قبل الامر ما
اجى ف قوله تعالى قل ان الله يضل من
يشاء ويهدي اليه من اناب الذي هداه الله
هداه بماذا بفعله وشاء الله هذا الفعل لكن
ما عليك من هذا الانسان
يسعى الانسان يسعى في
الهدايه ليس للانسان ان يحتج على الله
بفعل الله الله فعال لما يريد يفعل ما
يشاء لا يسال عما يفعل واما الانسان فهم
يسالون الناس يسالون الله يرسلوا الرسل
ويسال فيما بعد يقول الذين امنوا وتطمئن
قلوبهم هذا وصف للمنيب من هو المنيب يقول
الذين امنوا من اناب الذين امنوا وتطمئن
قلوبهم لذكر الله بذكر
الا بذكر الله تطمئن
القلوب هذا ونكتفي بهذا القدر ان شاء الله
ونسال الله تعالى ان يتقبل منا اجمعين
اعمالنا وصيامنا وقيامنا
وصدقنا وكل عام وانتم بخير وجزاكم الله
خيرا
ال number
25 28 الله سبحانه
وتعالى
thees ‏people of
paradise these verses now
are regarding the people of the
hellfire
conversely however we can see that the
people of the hellfire here are
mentioned almost in
passing
because the people of paradise are
mention in detail they have a number of
verses which very ‏clearly
describe the
actions and the belief of the people of
paradise which land them in
paradise however the people of
disobedience the people of the
hellfire their descriptions in the
hereafter are mentioned almost
conversely and
very
‏to the people of paradise and we are
tak more to the actions of the people of
the hell fire in life attitudes things
ar so الله سبحانه وتعالى and as for
those
who and as for those who unwind
or unti loosen
‏spe those
who
on
on to and
agement
serv ti
الله
main
andur
‏and for them is the wor of
places
now
what
قران الله سبحانه
وتالى لعن
الله
الله الله سبحانه
وتالى الله سبحانه
وتعالى
‏out and
d cured and ex from الله from الله
mercy صلى الله عليه
وسلم
الله
that any
قران
‏it is counted at least 10f we do a bad
de and counted only as one or
forgiven and so a person has to do 10
times the amount of sin that they do
good in order to break
even so a person has to work diligently
they have to be committed
‏be audacious enough and bold
enough ext from الله سحانه وتالى merc
me that we take for gred taking mercy
for gred is one the very
ways
الله
wor الله سبحانه وتعال goes on to mention
the attitudes the behaviors the belief
of the people of the hellfire which
landed them there he
says bounty upon ch and
‏ti upon
ches
so سبحانه
وتالى proud of what they have been given
in the life of this world yet really the
life of
this
‏who disb they say if only he to us a
evidence sign miracle from his lord said
the begin the chap and me here is the
propet
علس
‏the validity of his messengers of his
propet however they want they want a
proof from their own choosing do this
for us do that for us the purpose of mir
is performance entertainment those who
ask such questions and make such request
only do so
‏always resp that be respons to
that and
fally goes against the nature of
revelation nature revelation that
humanity
from the nature of revelation go against
human
‏against human wis human
desir human nature
if الله سبحانه
وتالى الله
does those he chooses and he guid to
him
those الله سبحانه
وتى he men use for guidance and that
is
turn الله سبحانه وتالى more gener serv
he
says those who
believe ‏and hearts trity
ined الله سبحانه
وتالى سبحانه
وتالى والحمد لله رب العالمين وصل اللهم
وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين والحمد لله رب
[Silence]
العالمين
‏l